today we're going to be talking about
wine law school is hard and how to make
it easy and fun believe it or not it can
be fun I remember in high school
everyone said college was going to be
twice the work of high school and when I
got there I found that it wasn't so much
harder than it was just different law
school is the same way it is very
different from college and while most
people think it's harder a lot of that
is just a self-fulfilling prophecy it's
more accurate to say law school is
different now everyone would of course
agree that in law school you'll read
more the reading is challenging the
subjects are unlike anything you've seen
before and you won't really have a frame
of reference for those subjects it's
incredibly stressful and oh yeah your
entire professional career as a lawyer
rests on getting good grades so there's
that but most would say that law school
is hard I think mainly because of the
lack of feedback the lack of feedback
makes people insane they study
constantly but because there is so
little feedback they don't know if
they're doing the right thing you work
for an entire semester studying complex
systems of law and it all comes down to
a single final exam and here's the real
issue the final exam is a test that is
nothing like anything in undergrad hell
it's nothing like the LSAT as a result
many people study the wrong things and
what's worse than that they study the
wrong things for a long time they spend
hundreds of hours studying things that
won't help them on the final when you
get to law school you have to think
about the end game the end result and
then work backwards from there we have a
ton of videos on how to succeed in law
school we'll put them in the links down
below but suffice to say there are lots
of ways to create feedback during the
regular semester and to figure out
what's going on before you take the test
most importantly you can improve your
law school test taking skills before you
get to the final this is probably the
single biggest miss off
in all of law school not learning how to
write law school essays it's just like
the LSAT you'll still have to study but
you have to learn the strategies and
improve your score over time and you do
that by practicing but most people don't
do that why because if they did they
might confirm their worst fear that they
are no longer at the top of their class
but it's coming anyway whether they
avoid it or not and by avoiding the
necessary practice it again becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy one of the
biggest problems in law school is that
it's a game that nobody tells you the
rules and think of it like this if you
wanted to play chess but your partner
refused to explain how the pieces moved
you'd be in big trouble and it's the
same with law school but once you know
how the pieces move you can learn
strategies that will tell you how to
move those pieces why you're doing it
and when you know what you're doing you
can start crushing your opponents and
it's the same in law school once you
learn how to take a law school essay
exam you can then start crushing those
to law school takes hard work and
there's no getting around that but most
people work harder than they need to and
they make it harder on themselves trust
me once you start taking practice exams
you'll understand how the law works
you'll understand how to apply it and
that will make your studying so much
easier don't be one of those students
who works too hard for too long on the
wrong things learn the strategies get an
edge and like anything when you get good
at something you start having fun
believe me when you get aids in law
school you'll start having a lot of fun
oh and by the way if you want to get
better grades on your next law school
final check this out we've put together
a free ebook called the ultimate guide
to crushing law school finals just click
the link below to download you'll show
you exactly how to prepare for your next
final including how to plan how to
outline and how to study for your next
file just click the lock also if you
like this video please subscribe to our
Channel we come out with new videos on
how to crush law school all the time so
thanks from everyone here at legally
[Music]